.
In the last presentation, I have told you that if we have a quadratic equation
In the form of ax ^ 2 + bx + c
= 0, you can use the squared formula to find
The solutions of this equation
The quadratic formula was x
The solutions are equal to + b or -
Square root of b ^ 2 - 4ac, each
That is divided by 2a
We learned how to use them
You only make up the values ​​of a place a, b place b
And c where c, and then will give you two answers, because you have
+ Or - here
What I want to do in this show is
Prove it to you
To prove that using the use box, I can
From moving from this to that
If the first thing I want to do, even start
Complete the box from here point, is
- Let me write the equation here - if we have an ax
- Let me write it in a different color - I have ax ^ 2 +
bx + c = 0
What I want to do first is to swear everything on a
I have 1 lab here
So we divide everything on a, and get x ^ 2 + b
/ ax + c / a = 0 / a, ie
Still equal to 0
Now we want to - well, let me move the words c / a to
Right side, so let's ask c
/ a from both parties
And we get x ^ 2 + b / ax + - well, you will
Leave a void here, because that will be gone now
We have put it from both sides - = -c
/ a, I left a blank here so we can
We complete the box
As you see in the complete box view, you will
You take half of the lab here
And you are squaring it
If the output of b / a 2 2?
Or what is the output of 1/2 × b / a?
Well, this is equal to b / 2a, of course will
We square it
We take half of this and we square it
This is what we do in the hopes square, in order
We can turn this into a whole box of binary equation
Now, of course we can add (b / 2a) ^ 2 to
Left side only
We have to add them to both sides
If we have (a + b / 2a) ^ 2 here as well
what is happening now?
Well, that phrase is here
It equals (x + b / 2a) ^ 2
If you do not believe me, you'll hit them
That is (x + b / 2a) ^ 2 = (x + b / 2a x) x
+ b / 2a), x x x = x ^ 2
x × b / 2a = positive b / 2ax
We have b / 2a × x, and this is also equal to b / 2ax
Then we have (b / 2a) (b / 2a), this is a positive value
(b / 2a) ^ 2
This and that are equal, because they are
The two expressions in the middle, ie (b / 2a) + (b / 2a), are equivalent
2b / 2ax, equivalent to b / ax
If this simplifies to x ^ 2 + b / ax + b
/ 2a) ^ 2, which is exactly what we wrote
There
This was the purpose of adding this phrase to both
The two parties, until it becomes a full square
If the left side simplifies this
Perhaps the right side is not that simple
Maybe we'll leave it on the way it is now
In fact, let me simplify it a bit
If we can rewrite the right side
It will equal - well, this
It will become b ^ 2
I'll type that phrase first, let me type it
In green
That phrase can be written as b ^ 2
/ 4a ^ 2
What is that phrase?
How will it become?
It will become - for me we get 4a ^ 2 in
Place, we have to hit the rugs and
Located at 4a
This phrase becomes
4ac / 4a ^ 2
You can check your own that this
Equivalent to that
I hit the rugs and
Located at 4a
In fact, we delete the 4 and this is deleted
And we have c / a
If this and that are equal
I've changed what I wrote first, and maybe you are, of course
You see the beginnings of the quadratic formula here
This I can rewrite
The right side here, I can rewrite it as b ^ 2
- 4ac, all divided by 4a ^ 2
It seems soon
Note that b ^ 2-4ac is already visible
We do not have to take the square root yet, but we did not take
The square root of both ends of these
Equation, so let's do it
If you take the square root of both sides, the left side
X + will become - let me down a little -
x + b / 2a becomes positive
Or minus the square root of this object
The square root of this is the square root
For the numerator / square root of the denominator
The positive or negative quadratic root will be b ^ 2
- 4ac / square root of 4a ^ 2
Now, what is the square root of 4a ^ 2?
It's 2a, is not it?
2a ^ 2 = 4a ^ 2
is not it? 2a ^ 2 = 4a ^ 2
The square root of this is so
Until we move from here to here, I take the square root
For both ends of equation
Now, it looks close to the quadratic formula
We have b ^ 2 - 4ac / 2a, now
We have to ask these b / 2a from both ends
The equation is over
Let's do it
If we put b / 2a from both ends of this
Equation, what do we get?
We get x equal to -b / 2a + or -
The square root of b ^ 2 - 4ac / 2a, that is
The common denominator
If this is equal to -b
Let me do this with a new color
The color orange
-b + or - square root of b ^ 2 -
4ac, all divided by 2a
We're done!
After completing the box with general parameters in front of
a, b and c, we can derive
Quadratic formula
in this way
I hope you found this fun